so ist schon mal mit ihnen üben wollen
sie schon mal beleidigt werden oder er
hätte man sich freue mich sehr dass die
zeit für uns haben ich wollte ganz am
anfang des gesprächs auch einfach mal
danke sagen für den umwelt beitrag der
eu nirgendwo wird so viel recycelt wie
hier zumindest wenn es um deutsche
politiker karrieren geht ja ja ja dass
das dass das war früher mal so dass man
sagt hast du noch einen opa schick ihn
nach europa ich bin auch jetzt oper seit
einem jahr und in europa und in europa
sie sind ja für den green deal
verantwortliche und gelten deshalb auch
als der einflussreichste eu kommissar
was ist dieses superlativ wert es ist ja
trotzdem das vize präsidentin der eu
kommission also ich formuliere es mal
anders die schnellste schildkröte bleibt
ja eine schildkröte stimmt stimmt und
ich kann nur vorschläge machen die ich
dann für breite und hoffe dass es eine
mehrheit bekommt und dass es umgesetzt
wird also schildkröte passt ganz gut als
vergleich ja ich akzeptiere diesen
vergleich aber eine schildkröte die sich
bewegt und die nicht die man nicht
aufhalten kann
der dicke starke schildkröte wenn sie
das so wollen okay wir haben uns die
energiewende in deutschland angeguckt
und wir sind zu dem entschluss gekommen
europa muss uns helfen was kann die eu
kommission was kann die eu tun der grüne
deal hilft uns unsere wirtschaft unsere
gesellschaft umzugestalten in eine
nachhaltige gesellschaft weil wir einen
binnenmarkt haben auch in ganz europa
können wir das auch am besten auf
europäische art und weise machen wenn
man die schlussfolgerung aus diesem aus
diesem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgericht zieht und zieht
das deutschland nachlegen muss bei der
nachhaltigkeit
das kann deutschland nicht alleine dazu
braucht deutschland tatsächlich europa
und wir werden auch versuchen da zu
helfen für uns in deutschland für unsere
politiker wäre es einfach wichtig dass
die ganzen unbeliebten maßnahmen von der
eu durchgesetzt werden so dass wir dann
weiterhin sagen können die us schuldner
so geht es immer also sie sind bereit
die rolle auszufüllen auch dazu sind wir
ja dazu sind wir da
das ist schon immer so wenn etwas gut
geht haben wir es getan wenn etwas nicht
so gut geht dann ist europa schuld also
das wäre so ein kompromiss worauf man
sich einigen kann sie machen das gute
und werden dafür beleidigt ja gut gut
wenn das dazu führt dass wir tatsächlich
unsere gesellschaft umgestalten dass wir
tatsächlich nachhaltig werden da bin ich
dazu bereit auch als sündenbock zu
funktionieren kein problem also jetzt
schon mal mit ihnen üben wollen sie
schon mal beleidigt werden oder wirklich
sie die eu denn sowas hört man doch dann
oder ja und sie auf englisch sagt man
dann an elected faces bürokratie naja
bürokraten das ist was meint mein sohn
sagt das auch immer dann dann zu ihnen
zu trinken wir eine tasse kaffee am
morgen sagt guten morgen du anwärter
gibt sich lose bürokrat und dann sagen
sie ich hätte für dich die welt und er
sagt auch geh mir weg nach brüssel
nee ich gebe das gute an unserem green
deal ist dass wir massive unterstützung
der jugend haben in europa ohne jugend
gebe es überhaupt keinen green deal
die eu will jetzt mit dem green deal
wirklich voran gehen wie passt das damit
zusammen dass das eu parlament immer
noch zwischen brüssel und straßburg hin
und her pendelt das ist einfach so dass
die mitgliedstaaten sich bei den
verträgen darauf einig sind dass wir das
so machen das parlament kann nicht
selber entscheiden
aber sie sind doch der eu
umweltkommissar sie müssen daran aber
aber ich muss auch unsere verträge
respektieren wir aber wenn verträge dumm
sind muss man sie ändern das ist je
handy war das können wir nicht machen
das müssen die mitgliedsstaaten machen
und die wollen das nicht sie sind ja als
niederländer für den green deal
zuständig ist das ein vorteil weil
irland ja von einem steigenden
meeresspiegel direkt betroffen wäre
jetzt von der motivation her ja ja ich
glaube schon dass es hilft aus einem
land zu kommen wo die leute
gut wissen dass wenn es schiefgeht dass
wir das risiko haben dass wir
verschwinden unter wasser verschwinden
also man kann mit der natur sich
auseinandersetzen und lösungen finden
also das haben wir schon seit seit seit
dem mittelalter entdeckt
wenn wir jetzt übers kiffen oder mit der
natur auseinandersetzen
ja das ist wieder ein anderes thema
[Musik]
kommen wir zum thema gebäudesanierung
das war wirklich ein großes thema
gebäude sind ja für 40 prozent der
energie in europa verantwortlich
30 prozent der emissionen das denkt man
ja so erstmal gar nicht erwähnen aber
kurzstreckenflüge wieso ist das so
naja das thema transport ist wichtig
weil dort die emission nicht runtergehen
aber steigen bei den gebäuden erreichen
wir weniger als was notwendig ist also
da müssen wir auch nachlegen ist aber
nicht so klar
für viele bürgerinnen und bürger dass es
dort auch ein problem gibt wir
reduzieren den energieverbrauch bei
gebäuden um ungefähr ein prozent
jährlich
das muss mindestens zwei prozent
jährlich sein
das sind unsere ziele so eine
energetische sanierung ist ja sehr
aufwändig wäre eine heiße sanierung
nicht einfacher sprich man zündet den
ganzen bus an ob die versicherung zahlt
das würde ich nicht empfehlen vorbild
weder kaiser nero bis 2030 will die unia
55 prozent der treibhausgasemissionen
reduziert haben gegenüber 1990
ich will ja auch helfen ich hätte
vielleicht auch noch ein paar
einzelmaßnahmen die ich vorschlagen
würde dass wir da weiter vorankommen
könnten würden sie sich die anhöhe bitte
also als erstes würde ich friedrich merz
beide privatflugzeuge wegnehmen
ok ich höre zu ja sehr gut also sie
haben's notiert sehr gut lutz anders
darf nur noch innerdeutsch urlaub machen
würde enorm viel beitragen zum klimaziel
und alle omas dürfen nicht mehr im
hühnerstall motorrad fahren das ist in
deutschland wirklich ein sehr großes
thema wirklich motorradfahren höhle
steuer
das ist neu für mich also sie haben
abgespeichert ich hab's notiert mal
sehen was wir machen können
auf europas straßen soll es ja bis 2030
30 millionen emissionsfreie pkw geben
die verkehrswende soll laut eu
nachhaltig krisenresistent und
intelligent sein muss es wirklich auch
intelligent sein darf auch blöd sein
wenn es nur klappt das sind gute
nachricht für an die scheuer okay zum
schluss wollte ich auch noch mal
explizit danke sagen dass die musik
ursula von der leyen kümmert wir machen
das gerne
[Musik]
kennt ihr das wenn ihr nach einer mega
geil feier irgendwo im nirgendwo wieder
aufwacht und dann dann wirkt eigentlich
nur noch eins alle heute schon videos
gucken leiden kommentieren und natürlich
den kanal abonnieren ja das machen wir
jetzt ja weißt du was mein handy